New Hampshire woman who won a half
billion dollars in the lottery is
getting her day in court
to try to keep her anonymity of course
my tamale line is Nashua tonight to tell
us how that's going this ticket is the
most valuable piece of paper on the
planet Earth
she purchased her ticket at a Merrimack
convenience store but beyond that we do
not know much about the New Hampshire
woman who won last month's five hundred
and sixty million dollar Powerball
jackpot and that's the way she wants to
keep it under a Jane Doe alias she has
hired lawyers who went before a judge
today fighting to maintain her anonymity
she doesn't want to be a celebrity the
central problem she already signs the
winning ticket as instructed on the back
a move she calls a huge mistake after
contacting attorneys she learned the
administrator of a designated trust
could have signed maintaining her
privacy and possibly her safety there's
documented history people who are
getting harmed people come into their
homes that's a real possibility whiteout
isn't an option as the State lotto
Commission says any alteration would
invalidate the ticket the integrity of
the game is at stake they say and the
rules cannot be bent we don't feel that
we can we can choose when we follow the
law and when we don't lottery officials
acknowledge the life-changing aspect of
jane doe's win and offered this advice
it's like anybody who comes into sudden
wealth whether it be an entertainer or
an athlete or a lottery winner she has
to learn the ability to say no jane
doe's attorneys in the state lottery
commission are working on a plan that
would allow her to claim her jackpot
without revealing her identity until the
court comes to a decision now it's
unclear when the judge will rule but in
the meantime jane doe's attorneys point
out that she is losing roughly fourteen
thousand dollars a day in interest Brett
follow that one Molly thanks